okay the Columbia School of
International and public affairs my name
is John cotesworth I'm the Dean we have
students from around the university who
are here welcome to you all one note
before we begin I have a previous
engagement at one o'clock for an
academic event a class actually and so
I'd like you to pay no attention at all
when I sneak out the side door partway
through the discussion over the past
year the WikiLeaks organization has
released hundreds of thousands of
classified u.s. documents some relating
to military operations in Afghanistan
and elsewhere many others classified
communications among State Department
personnel located throughout the world
the release of this information its
dissemination throughout the world and
the subsequent debate over how to assess
the impact of the leaks and their
publication raise broad issues of Public
Policy especially in the democracy the
purpose of this panel is to address
these issues it's a kind of an example
of how fast the news travels and how
quick SEPA can respond to events and
developments as they break so I want to
begin by thanking Cephas senior
associate dean Troy Eggers who first
thought of doing this panel and then
made it happen
so thanks now let me introduce our
panelists and thank them as they do so
Hasan Abbas the parent is the kayid yes
um professor associated with the South
Asia Institute he teaches courses on
politics religion and security in South
Asia
he is also senior advisor at the Belfair
Center for Science and International
Affairs at the Harvard Kennedy School
prior to his academic career professor
abbas served as a pakistani government
official in the administrations of prime
minister boot off and Musharraf
Emily Bell who's second here is a
professor of professional practice and
director of the toe center for digital
journalism at the Columbia Journalism
school before joining Columbia professor
Bell was director of digital content for
Britain's Guardian news and media and
was editor-in-chief of the Guardian
unlimited
well I'm Lieberman is next to Professor
Abbas his professor of political science
and public affairs here at Seba he's
also served as vice dean for the school
which is a life sentence actually Matt
and when he returns from sabbatical he
will resume that post his research
interests are in American political
development and his work has won
numerous awards including the Lionel
trilling prize here at Columbia Austen
long sitting next to professor Lieberman
is an assistant professor of
international public affairs here at
sequin professor long previously worked
as an associate political scientist for
the RAND Corporation serving in Iraq as
an advisor to the US military he has
authored deterrence from Cold War to
long war and spent as much of his time
on the ground in Iraq recently also in
Afghanistan professor Gary SiC seating
next Austin lon is an adjunct professor
of International and public affairs and
a senior research scholar at the Middle
East Institute professor Sigmund served
on the National Security Council under
presidents Ford Carter and Reagan and
was the principal White House aide for
Iran during the Iranian Revolution in
the hostage crisis that followed it he
is the author of all fall down
America's tragic encounter with Iran and
October Surprise America's hostages in
Iran and the election of Ronald Reagan
finally I want to thank president
Bollinger for joining us here today he
is a renowned First Amendment scholar as
you know and recently published a book
which I recommend all of you entitled
uninhibited robust and wide open a free
press for
society he also recently published an
op-ed piece in The Wall Street Journal
calling for strengthening the
government's role in financing
journalism creating an American world
service that can compete with the BBC
and other global broadcasters and
support a free press around the world as
it does so he has been enormously
helpful to see play and a great friend
and we're thrilled to have him here
I turned the conversation over to him
now to frame the issues and moderate the
discussion thanks John so thank you John
and it's a tremendous thing a sign of
the I think the vitality of this school
that something as important as current
should put together a panel of such
distinguished people to talk about it
and for all of you to come out in the
middle of finals or near finals and and
to think about this so it's terrific I
think there are several issues here that
are worth separating out and we'll talk
about the beech panelists can talk for
five minutes or so and then we'll have a
conversation here and then open it up to
questions the first question from my
standpoint is the First Amendment how do
how do we analyze the First Amendment
and public policy framework for question
like WikiLeaks and I'll come back to
that in just a second and and make some
opening comments there's a major
question that's posed by this about the
role of journalism and how decisions are
reached
what classified information to disclose
and which not to disclose and are we are
we happy and comfortable with the
choices that have been made in the
context of these particular disclosures
there's an interest also in government
secrecy and how how are the publication
of these documents and the purloining of
them
affecting our ability of the government
here and in other governments to operate
with some degree of obsequious II there
are very significant questions about the
effects on global security and global
public policy Foreign Affairs that
emerged from the publication not only
from the standpoint of the United States
but from other nations around the world
what are the consequences for foreign
affairs foreign policies and national
security so we've got the government's
ability to to keep information secret
got journalism and the choices that they
make about what to publish and we've got
questions both nationally and globally
about the effects of all of these on
foreign policy and security and I think
the last question and perhaps the one
we're least able to to analyze here just
because of the expertise that's brought
to the discussion is what does all this
mean about technology about where
technology is going about how it can be
changed about the ability of people to
get information and the ability of
governments to keep information from
being released so those are the major
questions I would frame going back to
the First Amendment let me just say this
in a very very quick way every society
has to every society has to come up with
some balance between the interest of the
state or the government in being able to
operate with some degree of privacy and
secrecy and the ability of the public
and the press in helping the public to
know what is going on in the government
we we all know as a just a reasonable
fact that we could not have an effective
government if everything that the
government does were to be public so
there is a real interest we all have in
in secrecy in government on the other
hand we also know that government
government's always over classify they
always use more secrecy than in fact
they should be entitled to it's just the
nature of the organization and therefore
there's a very strong public interest in
knowing a lot of what goes on in the
government even though the government
classifies it as secret so how do you
strike that balance and how do you do it
when you have a constitutional right of
free speech and Free Press well the
United States came up we've come up with
an answer to that question it happens to
be probably the most Pro disclosure Pro
Free Press result of any country in the
world but here's our answer the answer
came in Pentagon Papers in the 1970s the
answer is a messy compromise the
compromise is this under the Pentagon
Papers case and some related cases the
government can do any classification at
once there's no judicial review under
the First Amendment of how the
government operates with respect to
secrecy so if you say is a member of the
public or the press says we should know
what the government's policy is or the
papers are or the meetings that they've
had on X issue there's no First
Amendment right to get that so the
government can do anything it wants
consistent with the First Amendment to
keep things from the public on the other
side the press if it can get its hands
on any documents even documents that
have been illegally taken from the
government the press has a full right to
publish them and there are certain
limits on this and it's quite
complicated actually when you get into
the case the Pentagon Papers case deeply
and I may do that later but there is a
an exception for let's call it grave an
irreparable harm in the nature of people
being killed as a result of loss of life
as a result of publication but absent
the government showing that the press
can publish just about it
at once so it sets up what has been
described as a war between the press and
the United States government the
government can classify and keep
whatever it wants secret and the press
can try to get whatever leaks it can
even though they're taken illegally and
if it can get them it can then publish
it as it wishes for those people who are
leakers they have no First Amendment
rights so if you're a government
official if you're a super graduate and
you're going into the government just be
aware if you decide to leak information
from the government to the press and you
think you've got a First Amendment right
to do that because the press has got a
First Amendment right to do it you're
wrong and under the Espionage Act of
1917 there's a very good chance you may
spend some time in jail
should the government decide to
prosecute you one of the interesting
things about the last hundred years is
that as all of this was put together
there have been very very few cases
brought by the government against
leakers but in a couple they've been
quite successful and every government
says we're gonna go after leakers
because we're sick and tired of people
leaking but then when they do and they
really try to do it they end up not
bringing very many cases so that's the
basic First Amendment framework and now
I think the interesting question for
somebody like me who's spent their lives
thinking about the First Amendment
constitutional law and related public
policy the very big question on the
table is does the WikiLeaks case show
that the world has changed in material
and meaningful ways such that the
balance that was struck in Pentagon
Papers is no longer viable and that the
Supreme Court is going to have to
undertake a new evaluation of the world
as it is the WikiLeaks world and come up
with a different balance and we can talk
about that more in the context
of the general discussion but let me
turn this over now to Emily for her
comments Emily thank you I look at this
from the point of view is a professional
journalism and how WikiLeaks has changed
how we think about journalism and also
how we think about what the Free Press
might be in 21st century and I'm very
pleased that the president bones used a
very important word in relation to the
Pentagon Papers which is messy because
of course one of the things is that
we've we've used a certain set of words
to describe what we think is going to
happen to journalism in the digital age
and yet we've really lacked what I call
the proof of concept in other words
we've lacked an event which illustrates
how this is really materially going to
change journalism and I believe that
WikiLeaks was that event so when we talk
about journalism becoming about data as
well as about narrative what we want in
the stration of WikiLeaks is that when I
say it's been compared possibly
unfavorably to the way in which the
Pentagon Papers were leaked saying well
Daniel Ellsberg actually took much more
time and care in terms of the documents
that he was removing from the Pentagon
he did with a very specific purpose in
mind well he also did because actually
there's a physical capacity issue and
when he took them to the New York Times
they still needed a shopping cart to get
them from one side of the floor to the
other so in in the way that information
is going to come to light it's much
easier to download unedited large files
of information on to very small
removable devices than it is to actually
think how much paper can I physically
get out of the building so that's kind
of one way in which it's really changed
and if you're then an editor who has the
thumb drive dropped on their desk what
what do you do with it well first of all
you have to have the capacity to be able
to host and sift and publish that data
now for four years ago Julian Assange
and a set of release of computer
engineers but who had a publishing
philosophy and if you read
Assange's 2006 essay about why he was
doing WikiLeaks you know his philosophy
stands I would say it's an extreme point
to where the established press stands
now which is that the more disclosure we
can bring about the better it is for
democracy which is is dealing in a kind
of an absolute that most newspaper
editors in truth on a day to day basis
don't deal with so the first thing is
that it doesn't really matter whether or
not it matters I think for legal reasons
it doesn't really matter whether or not
you classify WikiLeaks and Julian
Assange as as journalists they are doing
part of the process that would have been
only done really by journalistic
organizations five to ten years ago so
that's a really significant change and I
don't believe it's going to roll back so
in other words I think that you will
only see more of this type of operation
rather than fewer what we also saw was
something of a kind of a light Shaun so
when the leaks had arrived we saw
something of the process now that
happens in terms of a new type of
network and distributed journalism so
one really crucial way in which
journalism changed to WikiLeaks is that
certainly in my professional lifetime
even at the Guardian I can count on you
know the things of one hand times when
we actually collaborated in such depth
and certainly at the same time as a
number of other in fact I don't think we
ever collaborated with a number of other
news organizations in the same way that
we did with WikiLeaks which is simply to
say well you know the world of
information is globalized and journalism
now that has become a real-time or a
genuinely real-time activity so the
coordination and the publishing and the
editing of the cables was done in a
collective and distributed way which is
very interesting and counter-intuitive
way for the press to behave and then
probably the most important thing about
this which is going back to President
bhajans point about having sort of
slightly messy rules around this is is
that disclosure is obviously done in it
in a messy and controversial way it
always has been and that's always been
part of the press presses roll some
to go too far and sometimes not to go
far enough because there are no hard and
fast rules in this area what we have
seen though is that disclosure now has
another element which is the free press
of the 21st century we imagined would be
the Internet and to some extent the
publication of the WikiLeaks documents
and what happened subsequently in other
words this idea that when you host you
know very few organizations which have
the servers on which to host that amount
of data so they very few organizations
would actually have the centralized
infrastructure that they had always
endured in other words the Guardian owns
its own presses it doesn't own the state
hey sorry not these days it doesn't in
the newsagent so that all the
supermarket's that distribute it but it
has a large control it has a large
control over how it actually sells
prints producers its product what we've
seen Illustrated is that actually the we
possibly don't have a free internet in
the way that we understand that we do in
other words the public sphere is not
regulated on the Internet and it's
largely taken up by private concerns
whose primary motivation is not to put
free information into the public sphere
so in other words if Amazon wants to
take WikiLeaks off its servers it's
perfectly entitled to do so because it's
a commercial organization if PayPal
wants to refuse to handle WikiLeaks
payments it's perfectly entitled to do
so if MasterCard wants to stop its
account it's perfectly entitled to do so
and I think this raises some really
really really important questions for
press organisations and actually for the
regulation of the internet in general as
we go forward about what this public
sphere might be and what the Free Press
and how how the how the functions of
journalism fit into that because we're
not going to be able to clarify
journalism as just a function done by
certain organizations bits of it will be
done in ways that we haven't properly
understood yet and WikiLeaks has really
sort of Illustrated how it might be done
and so I think that in some ways it's a
great time to be having this debate
because we've conceptually thought about
it before but we haven't seen what
actually might happen and we haven't
seen the pressure points and where
things break in relation to to freedom
of speech so I think I don't think it's
overstating it so this is a really
pivotal moment for journalism and the
way that journalists and journalistic
organizations will have to think about
organizing themselves and have to think
about how they engage with regulation
certainly sort of all change from here
on in ask each of the panelists as we go
a question or two one of the things that
was quite striking about the Pentagon
Papers case was that when Daniel
Ellsberg got these 47 volumes or
whatever they were of a history of the
u.s. involvement in the Vietnam War and
he handed them over to the New York
Times and The Washington Post the New
York Times in the Washington Post
reportedly called up the Attorney
General and said you know we've got
these 47 volumes and we're planning to
publish them we would be we wanted to
let you know that and we'd be interested
in and if you have any reactions about
this and of course the answer was we'll
see you in court we're going to sue you
and don't publish them when Bob Woodward
but they gave the point is New York
Times Washington Post gave the US
government and opportunity to go through
them and to say don't publish this it's
too dangerous and so when Bob Woodward
publishes his series of books about he
gets a lot of classified information he
gets a lot of secret documents I'll bet
you I mean I more than that I know
because I sit on the board of the
Washington Post company that that Bob
Woodward calls up the director of the
CIA and says you know we're thinking
about publishing this I'm thinking about
Pawnee
tell me if you think it's what I want to
know is did the Guardian do that in this
case did the New York Times do that did
alum own do that did how much
interaction is there at this stage of
life between the press
and the government over please don't
publish this please you know there is in
my experience and I can't speak
specifically in this case because I was
not an Alan Russ bridges office when
that when the conversations were being
held we know what happened with the New
York Times because Bill Keller has
written about and spoken about it which
is that they did contact the White House
and they did ask for their help in terms
of what we're redacted from the
documents in my experience it's very
very very unusual indeed for a news
organization when you have this type of
material not to have any kind of contact
prior to publication otherwise you would
or in other words you would always have
a conversation um it would be unusual I
would say to show them the documentation
not least because this is slightly
different case because we think we know
who leaked the documents we think is
bright bradley manning often just even
showing people the material in in a
document can lead to the disclosure
resource so normally you would never
shake you would never show the material
you might talk through it or you might
simply give a polite what we call
heads-up and one of the you know what
one of the interesting
I suppose issues that comes out of this
is to what extent particularly at the
moment when the press is not financially
as robust as it has been at some point
in the past of 30 to 40 years to what
extent it feels nervousness about right
being really seeing its core purpose is
holding power to account because that
inevitably informs the decision about
how much you involve your if you like
the establishment in deciding what is
and isn't isn't published about it well
that's very interesting I mean that's
that's counter to what one might think
that is you're saying if I'm running the
press a newspaper and and I'm really
financially strapped I may be less
inclined to publish it if the government
says don't publish it I think we're I
would think you would be more inclined
to publish it because you'd want more
sensational coverage and therefore you
would write I think that's I mean I
think that that that possibly it's also
to do the context of American press at
the moment yes yeah and I think that
national security has played a much a
far different part
in the past ten years in how the
collective consciousness of the American
press operates and that's substantially
different for instance to have the UK
and European press in reacts so The
Guardian has published more cables for
instance than the New York Times has so
there is justice or you can choose a
simple quantitative analysis of what a
US publisher thinks is newsworthy in the
public interest and what a worldwide
press think is in the public interest
just to pin that down in this global in
the new Pentagon Papers and we'll go to
Gary in the Pentagon Papers you had two
American institutions that clearly had
some sense of patriotism to the United
States right I mean which the souls
burger family and the grand family and
the editors and so on they would I
assume the Guardian doesn't feel and
Limone doesn't feel that they have a
patriotic interest to the United
no I think WikiLeaks surely does not I
think that is a fair assessment of the
situation I would just say oh you know
on the on but really talking about that
the non patriot patriotic nature
possibly the coverage I'd anything the
Guardian would have been any different
were at the UK government interesting
than we're not yeah what we were not
known for our patriotism yeah inverted
commas but but but it's an interest
again I think that this is where we've
really seen journalism change which is I
said before we talked about distributed
and networked journalism and
globalization and actually we now have a
kind of a proof of concept of what that
might look like yeah in other words
right in other words what the what the
New York Times is doing it knows what's
going into the public domain
anybody can anybody with an internet
connection can access any of those
cables and look at them on any site so
in other words it's a kind of a almost
like a brand decision on the part of the
New York Times about what it thinks it's
appropriate to publish rather than well
do you know what everybody's decided
that at some point this will be in the
public domain so we might as well go
ahead and publish it I think that's an
interesting nuance Gary we're all really
interested in
how you see the effects of all of this
on foreign policy and and is this a new
world in which foreign policy and and
security international and national is
going to people in the NSC in this State
Department this is my god I mean this is
we've got to get prepared for this new
world or is this life as usual well yeah
and of course having read all of that
and of course we've only a small part of
it has actually been released so far
we've got I think less than 1%
supposedly that has come out and some of
that is available in various sources
first of all I should say that I'm a
consumer I'm not I'm not a journalist
though I think I'm becoming more of a
journalist because the line has
similarly pointed out gets pretty
blurred sometimes in terms of what
you're doing I run it listserv I run a
website and I put stuff out on my blog
and so does that make me a journalist I
don't know but as a consumer I would
categorize this information dump in as
three different kinds first of all the
first category I would say is ho-hum I
mean it's really business as usual in
the international diplomatic community
nothing new nothing exciting a few
tidbits here and there perhaps some
confirmation of things that we didn't
know otherwise but basically that whole
first category which i think is more
than 99% of the wikileaks that i have
seen thus far could in fact have been
released next week or next month if
somebody had submitted an FOI a Freedom
of Information request it's absolutely
doable and so is this a huge secret
that's going to change everybody it
speeded it up and maybe this is
something that is true of the internet
generally it speeds things up but so we
got to the point of knowing about some
of this stuff
faster than we would have otherwise but
I'm not talking here 30 years I'm
talking a matter of weeks or months if
anybody wanted to put in a request
the second category I would call kit
elating this lets us peek behind the
veil of what people are saying to each
other in high places and listen to their
gossip and that's basically what 90% of
it is its high-level gossip and if
anybody who has spent time in the
government and reading cables including
CIA cables I must say that's what a lot
of it is is just gossip getting that out
in the papers you know I don't know as a
journalist is that there there are
things for instance we have the Arabs
saying to the American diplomats you
know cut off the head of the Persian
snake well maybe that shocked you but
you know it didn't shock me particularly
and I think that this is something which
I anybody who was a careful reader of
stuff that was going on would know that
and this is more graphic it's and as I
say it's titillating so it makes good
headlines the people who say that are
sometimes embarrassed though in the Arab
case I think they're not very
embarrassed by that the fact that they
don't like Iran is not something that's
going to hurt them terribly with their
own populations there's a third category
which is minuscule which I would call
harmful let me give you one quick
example I read one cable which has not
appeared in either the guardian of the
New York Times section but was released
by WikiLeaks which was about us
negotiations with a Middle East country
to buy back their manpads their
shoulder-fired anti-aircraft missiles
these are portable they're very
dangerous if they fall in the hands of
terrorists they could kill you and me as
we come in or out of an airport
someplace they and the government in
charge in this case agreed to let them
go to sell them back to the Americans
with the proviso that it be kept secret
before they had finished the transaction
this was made public I think that is
utterly irresponsible no matter how you
look at it and the fact that it raises
the question to me
what does WikiLeaks think it's doing
what is its real objective I went back
and read Julian Assange is so-called
manifesto that he wrote some time ago
and in a little tiny piece about op-ed
length he used the word conspiracy 33
times he thinks he's fighting
conspiracies that that is what
governments do they conspire behind
closed doors and so by throwing all this
stuff out there somehow magically you're
going to stop conspiracies from
happening I really looked at the stuff
pretty carefully that's come out so far
and I'm hard pressed to find a real
conspiracy that has been revealed lies
hypocrisy absolutely but anybody who
can't deal with you know lies in
hypocrisy has no business being an
international relations I mean that's
the name of the game so I don't I don't
call lies and hypocrisy a conspiracy
they are unpleasant perhaps and I don't
object to having them brought out in the
open but it doesn't change my way of
thinking because I want to leave time
for other people I will close off but I
do have one other point that I really do
want to make and that is that one of the
things revealed by these cables and it's
a irony which I think there's a thing
the whole thing is full of ironies they
actually we you know that they reported
over and over again as people were
talking to these American diplomats what
did they want they wanted the Americans
to come in and solve their problems for
them they weren't saying here is our
plan like the Arabs dealing with Iran
they didn't say here's what we plan to
do about those terrible Persians they
said why don't you Americans do
something cut off the head of the snake
attack
put in troops if necessary to solve this
problem at the same time other parts of
their government were saying to us going
in there militarily would be a
catastrophe for the entire region and it
seems to me we were getting a pretty
interesting story from the people who
were talking to us they seem to be
saying to their American colleagues I
will hold your coat in private while you
take action that I publicly deplore and
when it produces a catastrophe I'll say
I told you so that's sort of what we're
hearing from all of these other
countries I would love to see a
WikiLeaks dump on what goes on inside
WikiLeaks and I would also really like
to see a similar information dump in
terms of what's going on inside some of
the governments that we're talking about
Saudi Arabia Iran Central you know
Central Europe was a whole range of
countries that would be in many ways
probably more interesting than the
American cables
unfortunately it's like looking where
the light is strongest that's what
happened that's what they got and that's
what they're publishing and I think we
have to approach it with a bit of a
grain of salt about in terms of how big
this really is thank you Gary Austin
agreed quite a lot with Gary's
perspective on this I want to talk a
little bit about how this happened since
I'm probably closest to that part of the
equation when I worked in Iraq I had a
position not entirely dissimilar to that
of PFC Bradley Manning so how does how
does a lowly you know private in a
Forward Operating Base about 70
kilometers east of Baghdad get a hold of
you know not only the 260,000 on cables
but also a lot of data and operations in
Afghanistan and Iraq as well as some
video that you may remember that came
out last year from from various gun
cameras on helicopters how does that
actually happen
well I chalked it up to three sort of
related factors the first was after the
September 11th attacks there was a
there's a
huge outcry about you know how did this
so-called intelligence failure happen
and the diagnosis came down to a few
things
two of the most important of which were
a failure of imagination that the
intelligence community simply couldn't
imagine an attack of this type would
take place because they were too closed
off they didn't think outside of the box
enough etc and two there was not enough
information sharing and that you know
different parts of the government did
not receive information from from one
another and were therefore not able to
quote connect the dots so the response
to this was get people to think outside
of the box more and also to make sure
that that none of these stovepipes or
channels were blocked off and to make
information readily available and this
was uh incorporated into the same law
that created the Director of National
Intelligence in 2005 so that's one
factor that the desire to create outside
of the box thinking and the the spread
of an intelligence across the community
in order to prevent future attacks
the second was you know the same thing
that sort of swept over the rest of the
world in this time period the
information technology revolution you
know not so very long ago the term cable
meant cable like really you know
teletype cable as you would see in an
old movie now it's it's all electronic
the same is true of intelligence
reporting of all sorts human
intelligence reports signals
intelligence reports every kind of
report in the world is now electronic
and just as you can now you know do
various Google searches for for any
number of things
you know the intelligence community has
adopted a similar architecture so that
you can go searching for whatever it is
you think you need in order to serve
that that first function which is to
think outside of the box and to share
information so that that first factor
was amplified a thousandfold by the
ability to harness it to information
technology in the third and I think why
this came out of contingency Operating
Base hammer in Iraq and not out of the
Central Intelligence Agency's
headquarters in Langley or foggy bottom
or any place like that is you have these
two other factors interacting with a
military environment and not just a
military environment but attack
a military environment so you know it
there are various places you can go in
the world now that are essentially a
hole in the ground but it has a
classified computer terminal in it and
it literally has access to all the same
stuff that does the same terminal
sitting in Tampa or Washington would
have so the the strictures and
guidelines that that one would put in
place to manage this information I think
almost inevitably become more lacs
because people are worried about getting
killed not about a security violation so
in PFC Manning's case he was able to
bring in blank CD ROMs and pretend to be
listening to Lady gaga which I assure
you having spent 14 plus hours a day you
know staring at three or four computer
terminals you need something to keep
awake so everybody has headphones on
this is not unusual he pretends to be
latent listening to Lady gaga and he's
just click click click click yeah ed
probably 14 hours a day in the
classified environment 6 to 7 days a
week for months at a time in some sense
it's amazing he did not he did not he's
not able to sort of download more data
than he actually did so that's sort of
where this comes from is there anything
we can do about it
I think there is it will require
reversing a number of the things that
came under that first category you'll
have to make what's called need-to-know
actually much more operative rather than
being able to just do a google search
for any kind of you know secret level
information there there may be a need to
know and that's that's technically
possible that would require having
things like certificates I mean you you
you've experienced all these things in
your in your regular life you it would
just be translating into a classified
environment it can it can be done so you
know that's that's where this comes from
in terms of its importance I tend to
agree with Gary that that most of this
is overhyped
there's there's not much evidence of of
conspiracy and in fact we had ambassador
Khalilzad former Columbia professor and
ambassador Khalilzad here a couple weeks
ago and he described Bob Woodward's
recent book Obama's Wars as being vastly
more damaging
in every way imaginable then WikiLeaks
has been so far because it revealed
information that was you know classified
beyond top secret in a sense it was code
word level information about very
sensitive cross-border operations into
Pakistan and any number of other of
other things and this was not just some
you know private in in Iraq leaking this
these were senior US government
officials that pass this to Bob Woodward
so I well I think there are some
technical things that can be put in
place to limit the kind of damage that
occurred with WikiLeaks the reality is
as long as you know very senior US
government officials can leak the most
sensitive information in the US
government has and do so with impunity I
mean Bradley Manning's going to jail I
mean he's waiting for an article 32
hearing right now none of the senior
folks in the Obama administration going
to jail so unless that changes I think
we're gonna continue to you know the
United States is gonna continue to
suffer from these kind of problems I I
guess I all this is quite fascinating I
think to to go through I I said before
when we were just chatting before coming
out here that the journalists I've
talked to and Emily can speak to this as
well but journalists of major
organizations they feel that this is a
very very significant trove of
information
I'm just the thousand documents that
have been released and and and yet both
of you feel that it's actually apart
from gossip and maybe one or two things
really not that significant I wonder
just so we should talk about that some
and we will
is the government responding to this in
the way that you see it that is do Bob
gates and Hillary Clinton and the other
people sit around saying you know this
is not that harmful and we don't want to
because it's not that harmful we don't
need to take dramatic action to stop
this from being repeated or are they
saying this may not be that important
but my god what is what this shows is
the possibility of really significant
things coming out and we better take
some action or third do they say this is
actually really important stuff and we
better take some out where do you think
they fit in on on this he doesn't think
it's such a big deal and I always wonder
though whether it'll survive the shock
in terms of how big a deal it is I just
I hope all of you are familiar with the
National Security Archive in Washington
which D classifies information and they
have cables more recent than the
WikiLeaks dump that have been
Declassified appropriately and put on
their website and a lot of them are just
as interesting in some cases I think
more interesting than the ones what
bothers me most about the WikiLeaks dump
is that it's a dump it is it's
indiscriminate it's just whatever the
guy got it is being dumped out in public
and I don't call that journalism I mean
to me it's not just that it can do great
damage here and there there's going to
be some damage done but mostly it's just
irresponsible that it has no particular
meaning so when the Guardian narrows
that down and focuses on a particular
subject day by day
fine I'm all in favor of that or the The
Times boils them down and comes up with
several stories that's one thing but
just I don't call it journalism when you
just suck up anything that you get
anywhere and just dump it on the public
without any
I mean one of the Garre with just one
side comment one of the things that'll
be interesting in the First Amendment
context the framework I gave at the
beginning if this were ever to come to
litigation or prosecution against
WikiLeaks the way this could be framed
is is WikiLeaks like the leaker that is
like Daniel Ellsberg the the person who
assists or is WikiLeaks the press like
the New York Times and that will be an
interesting sort of characterization
problem Hostin note that I think there's
a tricky balance to be struck between
two of your points that I think that is
what the most government officials are
trying to walk right now
one is you can't say this is a disaster
because I mean that's that's terrible
and Gary and I you know clearly agree
that it's really not a disaster at the
same time you have to be concerned about
precedent setting if you say yeah it's a
bunch of secret cables who cares next
time it will be you know TSS CI
information that really could do grave
damage to US national security interest
so I think you have to sort of walk that
line between saying it's not that bad
yeah but not just saying well who cares
it's not yeah no we've already admitted
that things that are secret or not
secret forever and so what we're really
arguing about here is how soon yeah you
know and in his case he's saying last
February when I got this dump all put
together that's soon enough and that's
it and the government would disagree
yeah about some of the cables at least
yeah Robert well I want to begin with
with a little anecdote it's not my
anecdote it's William Safire anecdote
now some of you were probably too young
to know who William Safire is William
Safire was a longtime op-ed columnist
for The New York Times and before that
he was a speechwriter for Richard Nixon
in the White House and he used to tell a
story I heard him on television tell
this story a number of times about a
time in the early 1970s when he was
writing a draft of a speech for the
president about Vietnam using some
sensitive information that he had gotten
to help him
with the speech from Henry Kissinger's
office at the National Security Council
and hee hee because it there was
sensitive material on the speech he
wrote the draft wrote at the top of the
draft top secret eyes only no
distribution and then he gave the draft
of the speech to Bob Haldeman who was
Nixon's chief of staff to give to the
president and the typical course was
Nixon would read the draft mark it up
indicate what kinds of changes he wanted
and then send it back through Haldeman
to the speechwriter who would then
rewrite so Safire gives the speech to
Nixon waits a couple of days and nothing
comes back and he calls up Haldeman and
says I got to finish that speech for the
president where's the draft and Haldeman
says oh it's it's classified top secret
you're not cleared for top secret you
can't see it and sapphire says but I
wrote top secret it wasn't some security
officer who classified I wrote just
wrote top secret because I didn't want
it to be distributed too widely sorry
it's classified you can't see it
sapphire used this story it was much
funnier when he told it
sapphire used this story to make a point
that that Lee made and his his opening
remarks that's a very important point I
think and that is about the tendency
toward a government system like like the
American like the American system toward
over classification and he would say
when he told the story it's very easy to
stamp something top-secret it's very
hard once it's stamped to unstamped now
it happens and as gary points out there
are lots of things that are declassified
and there are ways of declassifying
things and sooner or later almost
everything will come out but I think the
so far up until this very moment this
very hour I think the WikiLeaks episode
has been in a large sense a huge missed
opportunity to think at a
slightly broader level about that
problem and about that issue about the
the sort of level and amount and extent
of classification and the culture of
secrecy that that surrounds a lot of
what the government does and this has to
do not just with national security
issues that's sort of the area of the
government's activity where the need for
secrecy is the most obvious and
intuitive but it's also true it's true
everywhere in the government in the
areas of government documents that I
tend to look at or not at all about
national security of they're about all
kinds of other things but still things
tend to be very tightly held and
government officials tend to get very
upset when things leak out beyond what
they the officials think is the proper
channels
and that there's that there's a sort of
a presumption that Lee Otley framed at
the top that the government should sort
of by rights be able to classify
whatever it wants without any review
without any question that it's it's the
presumptive right of the government to
say what isn't is not available for the
public to see that it's decisions are
more or less presumed to be correct and
that somehow to question secrecy the way
the WikiLeaks dump has has has done is
somehow seditious or unpatriotic and and
the presumption or the conclusion if I
can disagree with Gary a little bit that
this sort of dump data dump is
irresponsible in in the big picture
which isn't to say that there might be
specifically harmful things that it's
it's irresponsible to release for
reasons of you know this life and limb
of people that might be put at risk but
I think it's been a missed opportunity
for a couple of reasons one of them
missed opportunity to sort of raise
bigger questions about secrecy and
I'll say something about the role of
academic institutions and and scholars
and students in that in a moment but I
think it's been a missed opportunity for
a couple of reasons one has to do with
us Julian Assange himself first of all I
mean a lot of us have probably read this
so-called manifesto and other things
that he's written he's a dreadful writer
he's a very bad writer he's something of
a bloviator he's something of a mugged
megalomaniac he's not a very disciplined
or systematic thinker it's not very
clear what it is he's talking about most
of the time but to the extent that it is
the extent that at least I am able to
interpret what he says he it's extremely
conspiratorial he has this view that
someone else alluded to of the
government as a sort of big conspiracy
he's and he's - he's very stuck on this
sort of faith in technology or under
there's an understanding Assange
understands democracy as a as an
engineering problem right not as a
problem of human systems and human
behavior but as an engineering problem
and if we can just you know sort of
rewire the circuits so that all of the
information that the government has is
available then we'll break the
conspiracy because the the nodes that
are part of the conspiracy won't be so
linked to each other anymore in a closed
way or some or something like that it's
this is this is my best attempt at
glossing on what Assad seems to be
saying so I think that the the the
WikiLeaks ethos the WikiLeaks
sensibility leads us away from really
thinking about these hard questions and
difficult trade-offs about secrecy and
transparency
and lead us down the road of thinking
about technology and the role of the
internet and sort of busting open the
closed quarters of the government I
think there's also been a sort of
hysterical reaction on the part of a lot
of politicians in the United States Joe
Lieberman I cannot emphasize this enough
I am not related to Joe Lieberman Joe
Lieberman who's one of the most
distinguished and sometimes thoughtful
officials elected officials in terms of
national security affairs and military
affairs is calling to investigate every
one right and left all over the place I
meant to prosecute not just the leaker
not even just WikiLeaks but within New
York Times he wants to prosecute the New
York Times for heaven's sake for running
stories about these things and and and
running excerpts from these documents
he's proposed this you know amendment to
the Espionage Act to sort of change the
rules of the game the legal rules of the
game not that any of this will happen
but this is a very prominent serious
elected official he's not a complete
goofball for taking a very hard line
against any kind of flow of information
in this kind of way and at the more
goofball end of the spectrum Congress
and congressman elect Allen West of
Florida have you read about this guy he
called yesterday or the day before for
explicitly for censorship of news
outlets sort of prior restraint on what
they published that that not only should
the New York Times have to go to the to
the government had in hand and saying
well here are some things that we're
thinking of printing what do you think
that the government should be active be
able proactively to sort of stop them
from publishing things and he used the
word collaborators to describe media
organizations not clear collaborators
with what but it's a sort
provocative word so there there's been a
sort of crazed reaction inside some
quarters at least of the American
government to this some people have come
out looking pretty well looking pretty
good gates was mentioned Hillary Clinton
made a similar statement early on that
this will not probably amount to as much
as people fear Gates and Clinton pretty
much professionally have to say that
they couldn't very well go in front of
the public and say oh my god this is a
total disaster the whole edifice of
American foreign policy is crumbling not
a good professional move on their part
but even you know but but but the guy
who's come out of this smelling the best
frankly is Ron Paul now Ron Paul and
Hillary Clinton don't get usually
mentioned in the same complimentary
sentence so this is not a universal
reaction among among American public
officials but there is this tendency
toward hysteria about this that I think
has again deflected the public
conversation away from the bigger more
important questions about secrecy and
and transparency on the one and that
that trade-off in balance let me say a
little bit about that for a minute from
the point of view of academic
institutions we is absolutely right to
caution prudence if you're if you're if
you are if you your career goals have
you heading towards say the State
Department I'm for the for the moment
less interested in that problem then in
thinking about what should we citizens
of a university as teachers as scholars
as researchers and as students what
should our view of this whole episode be
and how should we in that role think
about the problem of this trade-off
between secrecy and transparency and
here I take a fairly hard line at almost
absolutist line the university as an
institution and as a place where
scholarly inquiry
happens depends entirely on openness of
information this is really extremely
true in my and Austin's home discipline
of political science where what we what
we do professionally is observe what
governments do and what government
officials do and what other people do in
relation to governments and and try and
describe them and explain them and and
make inferences about them and to
understand how government institutions
and governments and democratic and
non-democratic systems of various kinds
work
now is there a tension between the need
so so we depend for not just our
individual professional lives but for
the sort of health and well-being of
institutions like SEPA like Colombia
like any university on openness of
information now of course there are lots
of circumstances and lots of reasons why
governments need to be free from the
kind of scrutiny that we would like to
be able to train on them people need to
give leaders private unvarnished advice
their sensitive negotiations in which
people people's positions shift over
time and people say things that they
might not want to get out of the room
and then there are these there are these
cases where people's lives are actually
at risk because of discussions about
troop movements or operations in the
military in kind of military operations
that are coming that it would be really
dangerous if someone else knew about
there's all kinds of reasons why in
particular cases we should shrink from
openness you know and as we've heard
diplomacy is kind of a dirty business
there's lots of skullduggery there's
lots of gossip there's lots of sort of
embarrassing little tidbits but as I
think some other some of my colleagues
have already said these the leaks don't
appear to have irreparably damaged the
can the United States ability to conduct
foreign policy and in fact if anything
the the emerging consensus seems to be
that what we've seen so far shows that
the United States is pretty good at this
you know these are diplomats doing their
job what the government says it's doing
is pretty consistent with what it's
actually doing are there embarrassing
things that have come out yes you're um
you'd rather that foreign leaders
weren't flying around with you know
fifty million dollars and in cash
although I'm still scratching my head to
figure out how you would carry 50
million dollars on an airplane without
Pentagon Papers shopping cart Robert I
want to make sure we've got enough time
for questions so so but just one final
point I think that if as Lee says even
if his Lee says the United States is
that the more transparent end of this
the the spectrum as citizens of the
University it's our professional
obligation to keep pushing for
transparency and I think the question
that is how as Austin said to structure
the classification system so that we
filter out me that minimally the things
that are actually what you're ordering
Gary's third category the harmful other
than that you know bring it on so so
there's a very important point that
Roberts making that needs to be I think
just be emphasized and that is that
there is a kind of constitutional there
is a constitutional dimension to this
what are the rights of citizens scholars
and the press to publish what they can
get their hands on but there's also an
issue of public policy which is quite
apart from the Constitution and what
rights that gives us we can design a
system as we wish in terms of that's
what the Freedom of Information Act is
it's not a constitutional norm it's a
public policy it's a statute and I think
it's interesting what you raised is how
this has not yet been translated this
whole episode into a broader question
about how should what have we learned
from this about how the system should be
structured as a matter of policy in
terms of secrecy versus disclosure
Hassan thank you very much I begin by
seeing and actually repeating what the
previous speaker very rightly said that
indeed WikiLeaks is not the ideal way to
access information but as an academic as
a scholar everything every information
which is available in the market or
through any source it was irrespective
of the source is kosher for me kosher in
a sense for using it as within the
research tools having said that I'll
mention that it reminded me of moto of
the motto of my alma mater which was
gammon College Lahore in Pakistan which
was courage to know and I was thinking
about also in terms of courage to leek
and in the difference between courage to
know and courage to leek having myself
benefited from declassifying some of the
stuff in my book on my own accord it is
intrinsic it is deeply linked with this
idea of what is the ideally the
responsibility of a teacher and a
scholar at one level yes providing
objective and diverse opinions and
perspectives at another level it is also
the prime responsibility of a teacher
and scholar to be above any political
considerations any religious
considerations and I would even argue
any national considerations for a
scholar it has to be objective based on
the facts based also or on the
information that is available in the
market now there are of course dilemmas
other than this political political
religious and national considerations
there is another aspect which is social
responsibility and the dilemma that I
would read very briefly mention is I do
blog and the day the first the the set
of documents were released there were a
couple of documents released by
Guardian where there was a very specific
mention of some sources of information
which anyone in fact who's working on
Pakistan South Asian relations would
know that there was a mention or clear
reference in fact two names also people
within the garment sector working very
closely with the president and the prime
minister who went out of their way after
the meetings and gave information to the
US Embassy in Pakistan the challenge was
when I was mentioning those are
providing links to those on my blog
whether to whether to in fact mention
those two names prominently and of
course I decided against it but I am
just making this distinction of the
political and other considerations or
even national considerations with this
social responsibility at another level
it is very critical for us to understand
that to differentiate between an
academic in a scholar a lobbyist and an
activist as a scholar though as I had
argued you can use any information which
is available because that helps you lead
to to genuine rational objective
conclusions but at the same same level
you will not expect that from media for
example for from an activist or from a
lobbyist but I will also briefly mention
and move on the I one point where I
differ with with some of the esteemed
panelists is I think this is most
definitely a lot of new and significant
information which provides new insights
ranging from the the comments by the
Afghan intelligence chief that in 2009
he had received an offer from the
Pakistani intelligence that they are
ready and willing to to bring malama or
some of the other of Taliban leaders or
negotiation table and that when the funn
intelligence chief went to the US
ambassador in Afghanistan he declined
that whereas from the official
statements we get slightly different
image saying I think we need to also
look at how these Viki
this information was interpreted and
looked at with in other countries and
for example in Saudi Arabia we were not
expecting that anything will be
mentioned in the media but it hugely
impacts Saudi puffs on relations at one
level it hugely impacts Iran's
relationship with some of its neighbors
so it is very obvious to me that there
are there's new information for those
countries especially in South Asian
Middle East which will have a very
serious impact on US relations with
those countries and also for many of the
political leaders for instance this was
very insightful did you see that the US
diplomats in fact were regularly talking
to the Pakistani military chief and
those things which came out were quite
unexpected also one can critique that
approaches well why US ambassador or US
diplomats in any country are talking to
the military a military leads for
example on issues which are purely
domestic on issues which are purely
political especially talking to the
military leaders then give a very
different kind of impression and image
if you involve General Kayani in case of
Pakistan and political issues indirectly
you are sabotaging democracy in that
country so in in so many ways this is
the way these wiki leaks in this new
information has also been interpreted in
those countries and I think every we
need to look at that finally I'll close
with by my mentioning that what are the
components of a free academic or
university environment and I would argue
objectivity at one level freedom of
speech freedom of thought and a neutral
academic environment it is based on this
that that you can really pursue or go
for this pursuit of knowledge and I
think WikiLeaks whether we like it or
not whether the people who did it
whatever their interest was at one level
might be damaging for US policy
interests but at a larger global level
that provides more knowledge that might
provide
more basis of foundations for a change
in policy in in a creative fashion okay
so that's a really interesting array of
views on this and and that's what we
really set out to that's what we hope
for it that's what we've gotten what I
would propose is that in the ten minutes
we have 12 minutes that we take a number
of questions and then people can answer
if we take one question and then
everybody answers we're a few people
will end up with one question so if you
just take a series of questions there's
a microphone in the middle I gather
that's where people should go should I
begin I'm a neighbor of Columbia
University and I'm a fifty-year WBAI
listener member and caller you may
recognize my voice I am glad for any
kind of increased understanding of the
world because I went to Queens College
and graduated in 52 and I've gone to
Cooper Union in the art thing at night
and I've tried always to increase my
knowledge okay the point I want to make
sure yeah well it's about information I
was speaking to a chap who was firm in
his conviction of being a good American
and I said - and and and something came
up we were watching the TV of Holbrook
and the picture of him as in his latest
pictures he seemed like such a soulful
person would you agree he had this look
of the the future rather and the pain
now the point of what is the question
the point I wanted to make is at one
point I brought up to him he said he was
anti-gay and I said to him do you know
that Dick Cheney's daughter or and it's
come out in the press and it's a
knowledgeable fact
is je serai point I'm trying to make you
I wait a minute just wait a minute
please sir just ask the question the
point is he almost couldn't believe the
question the question is what is the
truth what is going on with our
government you spoke of conspiracy okay
would you say the war in Iraq was a
conspiracy against we shall we say the
American people okay so you've got a
language so we've got thank go too far
did I bother you my dear sir Thank You
Selina you might also wish for what your
incomes are yeah yes thank you next and
I think I'd like to limit the questions
to students okay this is sefa program
listen let's just abstain I'm a
first-year SEPA student I want to thank
all the panelists my question is is
there a possibility that whether or not
the WikiLeaks is handled they're editing
or the release of information very well
that they the organization come kind of
comes out of a vacuum of journalism I
think certainly a lot in my generation
especially those in an interest in
international affairs feel like
especially in the lead up to the Iraq
war especially the American media didn't
play a very investigative role in
journalism and that especially if you
follow the the 24 hours news networks
you might assume that the most pressing
issues in the United States are the
plague of homosexuality or the war on
Christmas that's a very interesting
question given what is widely recognized
as the failure of journalism to really
cover adequately a lot of the major
actions of the government in the one
does that stimulate a counter movement
that has more
disclosures okay we'll take that
question yep student yeah so I'm wanted
to know about the scenario after
WikiLeaks so if the governments were
more transparent enough the leaks would
not been added more significance so
thinking into consideration the future
government should be more transparent in
conducting their foreign policy or water
okay thank you very much thank you I
have a question I understand the freedom
of speech and freedom of press are the
basic rights for American people but do
you think such freedom has its limit
thank you freedom has its limits yeah
we're the freedom at limits question hi
my name is renee a undergrad at general
studies I have a question mainly for you
and Miss Bell from the media companies
you have talked to are they getting
ready for a big battle in the courts can
you sort of talk about that okay hi this
question is to mr. Abbas and I addressed
to him because I was able to listen only
your presentation but when you
distinguish between the qualifications
of the academics versus the journalists
and the activists and you somehow taking
a self-serving standing by assuming and
somehow how to really that the academics
have either higher moral standards or
higher intellectual qualifications and
most importantly
I don't know if any of you have already
seen and sorry president Bollinger
inside the job how bodily academics in
my own field economics and they
specifically about Columbia and Harvard
come across as ideas of just knowledge
for the sake of knowledge I mean let's
get real okay thank you very much hi my
name is sis Nova
I'm a Norwegian visiting scholar here
and I'm a sociologist I also want to tap
into the question of the higher ideals
of researchers and also sort of go back
to that this moment of being reflective
about secrecy and openness so could you
go ours so this is a question to our
busting Lieberman and because no one
here it talked about personal privacy
and that's the dilemma that I at least
see and especially concerning
researchers who I do think should have
higher standards than journalists thank
you and last question thanks for this
distinguish the castrum give us this
informative speech and I'm a parent
student and I also worked in a media
before I came to study in Columbia
University and as the president said you
gave the example about a petkin document
in 1970s and the systems I see some of
you are great at we surely so strike a
balance between a governmental
regulation and the freedom speech this
like the freedom press from the media
but how this balance can be strike
missile we can achieve that it's by law
or by regulation where do you afraid
that there will be saying that there is
a violation of freedom of speech which
is I think there's a fundamental value
for the United States and also for other
countries maybe in China because I'm
Chinese it's kind of a it's a like this
criticism it's about a way like
of the humerus and the press of freedom
and how do you think thank you great so
let's all give a run at this I'll start
by saying yes there are limits on
disclosures on free speech on pre-press
the United States has a whole bunch of
of limits on free speech free press
however the United States goes the
farthest in protecting free speech free
press I think the interesting question
that is raised for someone like me and
the many interesting questions but one
is I think a lot of the world is
wondering how much to go down the route
that the United States has done on free
speech and Free Press over the last
century they're wondering they've got
free markets going they've got huge
amounts of middle class and wealth
that's that's well how much should they
open up and I think we have to be able
to explain to them to the rest of the
world this is something that we have to
live with this kind of openness and of
course there have to be some limits but
not as much as you think and you can
cope with the world that has this kind
of rough-and-tumble openness and
messiness and that's not an easy case to
make on the world stage at this point
Singapore China a number of other
countries they don't buy this kind of a
see the WikiLeaks or the Pentagon Papers
as terribly undermining the trust of the
public in government we see it as
actually reinforcing the trust of people
in government and that's a that's a case
that we'll have to need
over the next decade or more is the
media preparing for a big battle with
the government in the United States over
this disclosure absolutely not there is
no chance in the world that the Attorney
General is going to be suing and
prosecuting the New York Times even
though I could give them a theory and
I'm sure internally they've gotten
theories that Pentagon Papers doesn't
cover this case just a theory I could
give it to them for a fee there is no
chance in the world that they're going
to that's the name that's how far we've
come
fifty years ago different outcome
perhaps not today um yeah just going
back to the question about has this does
this represent a Frank you have
highlighted a failing of the press I
think some extent it has in the same way
that if one thinks about think about it
as the underground press of the sixties
that again there was just a it is a
natural and disruptive I think
generational reaction to what is seen as
being reasonably poor service I don't
think it's unfair to say that the there
were journalists individual journalists
who wrote extremely powerfully and well
about why there were no weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq and there were
journalists who wrote very very sort of
powerfully and well about the failing of
very complex financial instruments but
they tended to be addressing an
extremely narrow audience they were not
addressing you know the Fox News
audience or the Builder audience and
2010 I think that most media
organizations are Paul so at the time
that WikiLeaks were doing it again this
doesn't endorse their methods or any of
their kind of that they're rather
muddled and and Paul thinking around
this most organizations didn't have most
even mainstream media organizations
simply didn't have that the technical
kind of foresight to understand that
this is how disclosure was going to
happen
and what that would mean so I think
there's a completely legitimate reaction
amongst people who have a deeper
understanding of this evolve people who
are younger to say that this is a sort
of a different type of dissemination and
disclosure and we're very very
disappointed with with the way and to
some extent elements of the press have
become completely calcified into the
establishment that they are meant to be
reporting on and it's not a bad thing
for the press to be reminded to the
extent to which that has happens as well
quick closing comments Gary just one
point on the coast Vietnam Iraq Wars
come up and I think this is all about
the Iraq war just to spending on papers
to solve about Vietnam basically the
American people feel that they would
betrayed by their government and by
their media and they therefore feel that
almost any remedy is worth it and I
think that's reflected in the ultra
conspiracy theory thinking of Assange
who that he thinks everything that the
government is doing is a conspiracy
sometimes it is and if it is a
conspiracy it should be revealed it's
just I would argue that in the
particular case that Assange has done
here there's no conspiracies and so he's
he's making an argument if anything the
dump of information that he's given us
is pretty conclusive evidence that the
government do other things besides
conspiracies and I think it disproves
this point actually
but in favor of uncovering conspiracies
by law in favor I just briefly on the
balance between secrecy and openness I
mean in a university environment I think
you have to be as Rob eloquently said in
favor of openness but I I do want to
defend the government's right to hold
things secret it puts me in a tough spot
I always appreciate having information
as Hasan said in order to make better
judgments but at the same time you know
people's lives really are on the line in
a variety of ways and the way the United
States understands the world is on the
line right because if intelligence
excuse me sources and methods are
compromised that's that's like a finger
in the eye
in the United States understanding how
the world works so there's a risk that
in trying to become so transparent you
you actually put cataracts in your own
eyes in terms of being able to perceive
the world so I think you know we always
have to keep that in mind secrecy you
know there is an over classification
problem but there is also a legitimate
need to do it in a variety of contexts I
want to say another word up to about
this see the the the secrecy versus
transparency question and about the role
of academics and researchers in this I
don't want to preempt Hassan's answer
because the question was directed at him
but I wouldn't I wouldn't say that
academics have or have a higher state
set of standards or higher ideals we
have one set of professional standards
and ideals to do what it is that we do
and and other people in other walks of
life as activists or journalists or
what-have-you
have different standards I think there's
a common interest among or there's a
zone of common interest among those
three groups in openness but I think
there that that comes for very different
different reasons and just on the
question of of personal privacy which is
actually one of the very delicate I
think complicated facets of this whole
question of openness I'll only say there
that obviously that's a concern it's
something that that we as researchers
always need to be worried about and it's
something that we as research scholars
and as universities actually have a
reasonably good system of dealing with
we do research all the time that
involves potential violations of
people's privacy we do surveys and ask
people things we we do medical trials of
we do all kinds of things that are
potentially invasive and violate
people's personal privacy and
universities and the government and
other organizations have come up with
decent imperfect but pretty reasonable
protocols for dealing with those things
think about the United States census
every year every 10 years we asked every
single person who lives in the United
to give us information we the government
right and there it's so we have
information on 300 million people none
of which ever gets released in a way
that's identifiable with a single
individual so we we as researchers know
how to do this but it's an it's another
important thing to throw into the mix of
this complicated
standards between different
organizations but I do know in the
history of relations civilizations I
think of an issue where the academia or
the people who are responsible for
teaching of teaching students the next
generation period they there were any
faults or inadequacies in terms of their
high standards of their thinking of
their responsibilities or profession as
a secretary sacred responsibilities
sacred in in in a secular sense a so I'm
not comparing but I think for force
cause especially involved in teaching
the right agents are different for video
Jainism of course I'm not saying that
it's purely or just corporate interests
or vested interests directly absolutely
not but I think there is an expectation
also in in terms of responsibility also
academic societies and scholars have a
higher responsibility portion thank you
we hope this was helpful to you and
interesting and thank you very much for
coming
you